do you think drugs or any type of
mind-altering substances contributed to
the creation of any of these oh yeah I'm
pretty convinced of it actually uh
there's lots of use for um
for particularly DMT uh in in the
ancient well I mean you can't the blue
lotus flower is one that's represented
in all the artwork I mean you literally
see images of it's like a smoking pipe
almost it's like and you're getting
showered with knowledge power and
stability or life power and stability
from the gods and some of those things
it looks to me like smoking pipes blue
lotus flower is full of DMT the the
acacia trees that's got DMT in it
um
see I think there's some of those
Visions in those Altered States some of
that geometry and things are represented
in some of the artwork there's been
mummies found with cocaine from South
America like in the linen from South
America go figure yeah and there's some
trade right they're probably trading
they're trading enough cocaine from
South America potentially there's
definitely been mummies found with uh
mummies in Egypt yes found with South
American Coke yes yeah yeah
yeah I don't know
don't explain it but does no one else
want to explain this why are you the
only one that's like we got to talk
about the Mommy's doing blow like that's
crazy
boomerangs in ancient Egypt the name
firm literally translates to Foreigner's
weapon like they're in the museum that's
not as cool as coach this is true yeah
I'm not sure on the details you'd have
to look at if you look up mummy cocaine
you probably find the details but yeah
let's look that up please
can I ask you while he looks that up
what are your thoughts on climate change
because this could theoretically a lot
of what we believe is climate change
could just be you know the younger
driest type things
I think that if you want to understand
climate change you probably need to
widen your scope of you a little bit and
look back a little bit further than the
last century or two is what I would say
because uh in a lot of ways to me the
modern climate change discussion is and
to borrow an analogy from
my friend George Howard it's like we're
sitting in a car arguing about the radio
station and what channel we're listening
to but we're ignoring the fact that the
car's sitting on a railway track and the
train's coming we've got bigger problems
I I think and if you look if we burn
wait a minute what do you know you know
some [__] well is there a comment coming
no I don't know I don't know on a long
enough time scale 100 it depends on what
that time scale I think he's just saying
we are in this Cosmic Shooting Gallery
it's only a matter of time yeah and it's
look if we burnt every last ounce of
fossil fuel and the end result of that
was that we averted the next Cosmic
impact then karmic debt paid yeah like
there's nothing like the climate change
that is a result and the pollution of a
comment of a of us of a cosmic impact
like that like you want nuclear winter
like that's what it is like it blocks
out the Sun for for hundreds of years
everything on Earth dies you know you
can't you can't breathe outside like the
half of the world is on fire kind of
thing like that's
it's apocalyptic in other words that's
what it means and that's not speculative
like I remember yeah you were telling me
that like there's there's a piece of the
Bedrock that you could see that was on
fire or the remnants of the fire and
this exists throughout the Earth this is
like a black matte lie at that at that
at that um at that younger driest
boundary layer in the soil in the strata
there is a an Organics like a suit layer
almost where it's in the the
calculations of something like nine
percent of the organic matter on the
planet was on fire which is
an astronomical and it's just an ash
layer yeah in the bed it's literally yes
it's all out from the fires yeah it was
either flood or fire like you look at
every ancient culture it's flood or fire
like it's either cataclysmic fire or
it's world ending floods like kind of
makes you feel lucky huh yeah well
that's the thing you know we've people
complain about it but honestly our
climate has been the most stable it's
we've had the best climate in the last
sort of ten thousand years that we've
had for almost two hundred thousand
years like yeah on the planet so that's
so when you talk about modern climate
change we're arguing about CO2 yeah and
like a tenth of a degree
I don't care it's fine look that's not
to say pollution bad treat the planet
good yes like let's clean up our act do
all that stuff but we have bigger the
reality is also CO2 is not a problem
more CO2 is good the planet nearly went
into plant death uh in the little ice
age that warmth is great we've been far
warmer and had far more CO2 in our
history on this planet and supported
Mega fauna and mega floral are likes of
which don't exist at all and it's when
it gets colder cold is the problem small
cold periods Associated guess when the
the black plague was period all of the
downtons oh because the heat is going to
burn off a lot of the bacteria well just
you just cold periods are associated
with famine and and less plant growth
which means yeah your immune systems are
weaker you don't eat as much and you
yeah all the stuff you can't grow in
cold and then we're very much like
bacteria in that way yeah pretty much I
was thinking it was going to get burned
off in the heat but you're right that
makes sense and also just the weakness
of the body if there's no like famine
yeah Winters are just rough in general
yeah yeah Cold's bad and and cold is
worse than getting warmer like this
whole plants on fire is nonsense like
it's fine in fact the planet is Greening
like we now you've seen the evidence for
this like the plants actually Greening
due to the slight increase in CO2 CO2 is
not a pollute and we shouldn't be
demonizing CO2 it's fine uh like I said
in the past we've had many times the
number of CO2 that we've had we have
today it's not a big deal we've never
had a runaway climate the climate on
this planet is very stable even when
things like Cosmic impacts happen it
recovers like it's a very stable system
and just to clarify so you don't get
yelled at that's not to say there's no
problem with pollution oh yes yes there
are other problems yeah it's not
necessarily what we think it is I hate
having to preface that all the time by
saying well if you somehow question any
of the narrative it's like you're
pro-pollution like of course pollution's
bad let's clean up our head let's keep
the oceans clean all these things yeah
let's do let's behave like responsible
stewards of the planet but but if
polluting was making it colder let's not
tax everything that's a bigger issue yes
I think it'd be a bigger problem too
yeah it would be it cold is bad cold is
bad what'd you find here so this is a
German toxicologist basically did a
study on the hair of uh of a priestess
that they uncovered cocoa and they yeah
they basically found traces of nicotine
and cocaine which had been considered to
be cocoa and tobacco plants native to
the Americas that were not thought of
been brought to Africa until after
Columbus's voyage
well I I do think that dynasty we don't
give the dynastic Egyptians enough
credit for what they do I think they
were probably much wider ranging I mean
they had bigger boats than the Vikings
and we know the Vikings got around a lot
of times I thought we haven't found any
boats from there plenty of boats they're
mostly riverboats though they wouldn't
last the sea voyage that said you can go
to places like hapshup shit's Temple and
there's literally scenes on the wall of
ocean voyages where there's fleets of
ships they're even drawn underneath
there's like it's like uh ocean
creatures that you don't get in the Nile
like they talk about an expedition to
what they call buntland uh to go and get
stuff at one point
um there's a place in Australia called
the Gosford glyphs that I happen to
think is probably a a result of a
Shipwrecked um like ptolemaic period
Egyptian uh crew there's these glyphs in
this place in Australia and this little
cat they think it's a hoax it's not a
hoax go go to this Gosford glyphs yeah
Gosford glyphs yeah gos f-o-r-d glyphs
and you're saying that the Egyptians
reached Australia yeah but it's on their
Maps too they literally show like horses
in America and they show dynastic
Egyptians yeah yeah ptolema make period
like late period Greek Roman period
That's the matches the glyphs that they
did they'd look poor because the story
that they actually that it tells we had
some of it translated was the Scribe and
the captain died I think one of them
died of a snake bite they were
Shipwrecked so this is the results The
Carving are the results of a guy that
could probably read Egyptian but wasn't
a stone Carver it's like you can
probably read and write on paper but try
carving it into sandstone see how far
you get but yeah yeah anyway so they've
known about this literally the thumbnail
for my video about it um they've known
about this since the 1970s uh the modern
um Dogma on it I guess is say well it's
a hoax some guy came back from the war
and was like oh I was in Egypt so I'm
just going to draw some random
collection of hieroglyphs on the wall
turns out that's not the case it
actually tells a story it's coherent and
what's even crazier is there are symbols
on this wall that we didn't decipher
until like the year 2000 so they did
they weren't in Egyptian dictionaries
until the year 2000 yeah they're still
on this war in business since the 1970s
and they still want to call it a fake
I'm like what's so hard to believe these
guys were seafarers maybe they just got
a whole bunch of storms Bloom across
halfway across the Pacific and they got
Shipwrecked down here they got looked
after by the local aboriginals they
lived their life
they buried their dead and they wrote
something about it on this wall do we
know what the story says yeah it says
that it was the part of it not all of
it's been decoded but the part of it it
says that yeah it was exactly that it
was a crew that got Shipwrecked here uh
one of them died from a snake bite the
captain and the Scribe
um died and then the locals were looking
after them like the aboriginals uh would
look after people like that happened a
lot with the white explorers too you
could make a pyramid
did a lot of amazing stuff they were
particularly by the end like the New
Kingdom and the ptolemaic period they
had a lot of capable they were
tremendously wealthy they built like
Karnak Temple short Sandstone but it's
spectacular some amazing stuff carnic
Temple k-a-r-n-a-k
um you know they they embarked on Matt
they were a massive civilization that
lasted a long time I don't want to
undersell what they were capable of yeah
we're just comparing them to the goat
well yeah there's just there's as
capable as they were and as magnificent
as they were there's just a few things
that are outside of their technological
capability and that one top left there
is
um that red one yeah top left there this
one yeah that's one of them yeah so this
is like these giant Sandstone columns
that's beautiful and that's all dynastic
work a lot of all those Rams those
dynastic work these big pylons and and
walls of dynastic they're huge
structures like the carnic temple and
Luxor temple they're amazing I think
they combine like a lot of a lot of
these structures combine both elements
it's like they they built a temple on
top of an old attempt or an older
structure that I think does stretch back
to
you know these earlier times with these
Granite artifacts the big obelisks and
the single piece statues made from
Granite that show all these signs of
precision like